في الكويت تصدر امير البلاد الشيخ نواف
الاحمد الجابر الصباح امرا اميريا بقبول
استقاله الحكومه التي يراسوها الشيخ احمد
النواف بعد ثلاثه اشهر فقط من تشكيلها
وذلك اثر خلاف مع مجلس الامه بشان الاتفاق
على مطالب شعبيه يرغب النواب في دفع
الحكومه لاقرارها قد جاءت الاستقاله بعد
اصرار الحكومه على موقفها بشان اعاده
تقارير اللجنه الماليه الى اللجان من دون
اي تعهدت
الكويت
شاهد مرحبا بك مدى بعد تقديم او موافقه
امير البلاد على استقاله الحكومه الكويتيه
بل خيارات او الاجراءات
نعم خالد طبعا هذه تعتبر ثاني استقاله
لحكومه رئيس الوزراء الشيخ احمد النواف
التي تشكلت في اكتوبر الماضي بعد هذه
الاستقاله طبعا سيكون هناك مجال ل اا امير
البلاد لتكليف اا رئيس وزراء جديد
وبالتالي بعد تكليف رئيس الوزراء الجديد
لا نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه ماذا سيكون هو
نفسه همم الشيخ احمد النواف او اا يعني
رئيس وزراء جديد هو من سيتم تكلفه لتشكيل
الحكومه جديده طبعا تشكيل الحكومه الجديده
سيكون من اختصاص رئيس الوزراء المقبل همم
يتم تشكيلها وتسليم هم او تكليف الوزراء
الجديد عده حقائب وزاريه همم خالد طبعا
هذه الحكومه التي يتراسها او المستقله
التي يتراسها الشيخ احمد النواف كان من
ضمنهم همم بين همم يعني تم اختيارهم من
قبل الشعب وبالت تحويلهم الى وزراء كانت
هناك طبعا يعني اختلاف في وجهات النظر همم
من حيث يعني همم عقد الجلسات في مجلس
الامه همم طبعا في السابق كان بعض النواب
يقولون بان كيف يتم رفع جلسات مجلس الامه
رغم اكتمال النصاب بحضور همم النواب مع
غياب الحكومه اليوم نرى بعض النواب تردد
في همم يعني همم في همم هذا الشيء ولم
يذكره رغم اكتمال اني صعب يعني في اختلاف
في اراء بعض النواب مع هذه الحكومه الجديد
او المستقيله
طيب شكرا جزيلا لكي يشاهد المتروك مراسله
العربيه من الكويت
اذا كان ولي العهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل
الاحمد قال في كلمه الله في 22 مليون
والعمل الماضي ان المشهد السياسي في
الكويت تمزقه الاختلافات والصراعات
والمصالح الشخصيه
والتحديات
والاخطار المحيطه بنا مع الاسف الشديد
بجمهور ومسائل بعيده عن الطموح ولا تحقق
المقاصد الشعبيه
الماموله والمنتظره فما زال المشهد
السياسي
تمزقه الاختلافات
وتدمر الصراعات
وتسعيره المصالحه والاهواء الشخصيه على
حساب استقرار الوطن وتقدمه
والزاره ورفاهيه شعبه
كما قالولي عهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل لاحمد
انه في حاله عوده الازمه التي مرت بها
الكويت من صراع بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه بانه سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات قويه
وشعبها فوق كل اعتبار
ونناشدكم ابناء وطننا العزيزي
الا تضيعوا فرصه تصحيح مسار المشاركه
الوطنيه حتى لا نعود الى ما كنا عليه لان
هذه العوده لن تكون في صالح الوطن
والمواطنين وسيكون لنا في حاله عودتها
اجراءات اخرى ثقيله الواقع والحدث
محمد السبتي سيد محمد حياك الله معك
هذه الحكومه الاربعين تقريبا صحح لي يعني
في الرقم على مدى تاريخ الكويت
يمكن عدد الحكومات التي استكملت مدتها
القانونيه همم سيد محمد اذا كنت تسمعني لم
يتجاوز عدد الاصابع الواحد الان امير
الكويت حذر من انه في حاله عوده الازمه
الى الحاله التي شيدتها الكويت خلال عقود
فسيتم اتخاذ اجراءات قويه هل سيتم بالفعل
الان تغيير هذا الموقف هذه الحاله حسب ما
حذر وحدد ايضا ولي العهد الكويتي في كلمته
اخي
سيد محمد
طيب يبدو
طيب قبل الذهاب الى ضيفي من الكويت نتوقف
مع هذه
مع هذا العرض حول الحكومات الكويتيه خلال
سته اشهر
[موسيقى]
ضيف من الكويت الصحفي محمد السيد محمد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه الان تعود
الكويت الى المربع الاول في المشهد
السياسي في حاله الصراع بين السلطتين
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه وهي الحاله التي
كانت عليها الكويت خلال العقود ماضيه
طويله لكن هل الوضع الان او المعالجه
ستختلف كما قال وحذر ولي العهد الكويتي في
خطابه الاخير بان بانه سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات
قويه
هذا هو المامول المامول ان نقتنع جميعا
باننا نمارس عمليه خاطئه
المامول ان تقتنع جميع التيارات السياسيه
الفاعله في الكويت ان ما نمارسه من 60 سنه
ليس الديمقراطيه هي عمليه انتخابيه ليست
مكتمله الدائره الكهربائيه لا يمكن بحال
ان تنتج الا عن طريق الصدفه نحن مارسناها
مرارا كثيره منذ 60 سنه ولم يعني تنتج اي
شيء الا بطريق الصدفه ما لم يقتنع جميع
تيارات السياسيه بهذه الحقيقه الواضحه جدا
للعيان فلن يتغير شيء لكن المامون من
الحكومه ومن القياده تتخذ يعني قرارا
حااسما ينقذ البلاد من هذه المتاهه التي
نعيشها اجانا بعد اجيال ثم لا نجد اي بصيص
انا همم من خلال هذه العمليه
ولقد تماما
اليوم نفس الحاله تتكرر نفس التجربه نفس
الازمه نفس الادوات نفس المكونات تتغير
الاشخاص
ويتم تكرارها
ويتم كما قلت ربما ترقب لنتيجه يعني مع
انه المنطق السياسي بيقول بانه اذا كانت
المعادله بهذا الشكل فلا يمكن توقع اي
نتيجه فبالتالي او اين توجد مختلفه
فبالتالي ما طبيعه الاجراءات التي يجب
اتخاذها اليوم دون اي تاخير
الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها هو همم هي ما
هو مقتنع به جميع افراد الشعب وحيد الفاضل
للمشاهده الكريم جميع افراد الشعب الكويتي
بما فيهم الحكومه مقتنعون ان هذه العمليه
تحتاج الى تعديل تعديل في الدستور تعديل
في الاليه لكن لا احد يجروا على هذا
التعديل لا احد يجروا على هذا التعديل لان
كل المقتنعون بالتعديل كلهم يرى التعديل
من زاويه فهم يعتقدون انهم في حال فتح باب
التعديل سوف يلجاون الى نصف هذا الدستور
ثم الاتيام الدستور اخر لهذه الخطوره يعني
يعجز الكل عن مصارعه نفسه بالحقيقه نحن في
مازق حقيقي نحن المازق الحقيقي اننا نمارس
فعلا سياسيا بحال لا ياتي بالنتيجه اي ان
كانت المشكله ليست في الحكومه وليست في
النواب وليست في رفض الدستوريه وليست في
مشاريع القوانين التي تطرح ليست هذه
المشكله هذه بعض ظواهر المشاكل التي
نعانيه من 60 سنه الاشكاليه الحقيقه
الحقيقيه في هذا النظام وهذا النظام متفق
على وجوب تغييره لكن لا احد يجروا على
تغييره همم ما لم يعني نص دم بهذه الحقيقه
نصد انفسنا ونظم الشارع الكويتي وتنصدم
التيارات السياسيه وتاخذ عصا السبق في
تغيير هذه الاليه فاننا سوف ندور في ذات
الحلقه المفرغه التي شاهدناها باعمارنا
وسوف يشاهدها في الازمه الاخيره لان لم
يكن بالامكان افضل مما كان يعني هناك من
يقول بانه من من من من الحق الدستوري
للنوا في البرلمان يقدم استجواب للحكومه
بالتالي لماذا دائما تكرر الحكومه كما
يقولون نفس المشكله نفس الطريقه في
التعاطي لماذا لا تذهب الى المواجهه مثلا
داخل او تحت قبه البرلمان خلال
من خلال رسوم من خلال احصائيات من خلال
ارقام تعالج المشكله او تعالج جزء منها
كمنطقه للالتقاء بين الاطراف في هذه
الحاله يعني
همم لست دافع عن الحكومه لكن حقيقه الامر
ان الاستجوابات تستخدم استخداما خاطئا
الاستجوابات سلاح تستخدم بطريقه خاطئه
بمعنى هذا الكلام ما تفضلت به هو حقيقه
الامر يجب على الحكومه ان تواجه تلك
الاستجوابات وانت تفندها امام الشعب ثم
تنتهي هذه الاستجابات ان كانت ان كان
الوزير على موقف الحق لكن الحكومه تعلم
انه اذا اراد ال 50 نائب استقصادها
باستجوابات فانها ما تنتهي من استجواب حتى
تدخل في استجواب وقد مارست هذا بعض الكتله
السياسيه في البرلمانات السابقه ينتهي
الاستجواب الساعه الثانيه عشر ظهرا الساعه
1:00 ظهرا تتقدم استجوابات وزراء اخرين ثم
تدور العجل الحكومه تعي ان استجوابات
المقدمه ليست انا لا اطعن بالنواب لكن
ليست محاسبه هذا الوزير او ذاك الوزير عن
بعض الاعمال هي نزاع راسي ان انتهى هذا
الاستجواب فسوف
يفتح الباب للسيل من الاستجوابات ضد
الوزراء او ضد رئيس الوزراء الحكومه تعي
هذا ويعيش الشعب ايضا وقد مارسدت كثيرا من
الكتل السياسيه لذلك همم ارتعت الحكومه ان
تقديم الاستجوابات في هذه المرحله يعني لم
يمضي على تشكيل الحكومه وعلى تسلم هؤلاء
الوزراء الا بضعه اشهر ثم تقدم ضدهم
استجوابات همم في ظني ان الحكومه ترى ان
مثل هذا التصرف هو استخدام سيء لتلك
الاسلحه الدستوريه وانه سوف تستخدم تلك
الكتل هذه الاسلحه همم بالسوء ذاتها متى
انتهت هذه الاستجرام اذا كان الحل هذا كما
تقول ويعرفه الجميع الكويتيين يعني سواء
كان على مستوى الحكومه او على مستوى
النواب
الكل يعرف انه هناك ثغرات يتم استغلالها
في هذه التجربه في الدستور الكويتي ربما
في العلاقه بين السلطتين ويجب سد هذه
الثغرات
ومعالجتها همم
من هو الرجل الذي اا يمكن يعني ان يحل هذه
المشكله اليوم ولماذا لا يواجهها بالفعل
لماذا لا تطرح هذه النقطه ويتم معالجه هذه
الامر بدلا من تعطيل مصالح المواطنين
والبلد
وجعلها تقف في خانه معينه في مقابل يعني
تقدم ونمو واقتصاد ورخاء ربما كما يرى
البعض في المحيط الاقليم
نحن امام خيارين الخيار الاول ان يتم
تعديل الدستور والدستور لا يتم تعديل الا
بموافقه ثلثي اعضاء مجلس الامه
والموافقه الاميريه الموافقه مشترطه
باجتماع
هاتين الفئتين سموه الامير وثلثي اعضاء
مجلس الامه ومتى ما فتحنا يعني باب تعديل
الدستور فسوف يعني تتشرد المواد الدستور
كلها لان
الاسلاميون يرون وجوب تعديله في بعض
المناحي ويريدون اصوات غيرهم اليساليون
يريدون تعديله في مناحي اخرى همم
الاسلاميون الشيعه وغير ذلك فهذا الخيار
للاسف لا احد يتحمل المسؤوليه لاننا نمارس
وهذه العمليه لمصالح يعني حزبيه في قويه
عائليه سميها انا قلت اكثر من مره
الديمقراطيه التي فارسها لا تنتج ابدا
يعني رجال دوله هي تنتج دوله رجال وهذا ما
نعاني
الحل الاخر المطروح ان تتجه السلطه الى
الغاء هذا الدستور وهو حل غير الدستوري
الدستور لا يبيح لها الغاء هذا الدستور
لكنه يعني انتهجت السلطه مثل هذا النهج في
اكثر من سنه في ال- في 86 في 76 مثلا يعني
اوقفت العمل بمواد بعض الدستور وهو ما
تعارف عليه الكويتيون بالحل غير الدستوري
وكيله الحلين مرين لكنه يعني للاسف اقول
لها وانا كويتي يقولها بالمراره لا احد
ينهض بهذا الحل المر لمواجهه تلك المشاكل
التي نعانيها اجيانا بعد اجيال ليست تستمر
الكويت في هذه الدواء في هذه الحاله من
الفوضى والعباسيه السياسيه لكن السؤال هنا
اذا كان الامر سيستمر بهذا الشكل
الناس ليش تتعطل مصالحهم
ليش تتوقف المناقصات ليش تتوقف المشاريع
القرارات هل هناك في الدستور ما ينص على
توقف هذا العمل العمل الحكومي يعني ليش ما
يكون في عمل حكومي على الاقل بغض النظر عن
المدير وزير موظف او اي شخص
تتوقف لان هذه العمليه البائده التي
اسميناها زورا وبهتانا ديمقراطيه ربطت كل
الامور في بعضها اصبحت اصبحت الوزير مرتبط
بموافقه بعض النواب لانه ما لم يسترضى
هؤلاء انه فسوف يفتحون عليه ابواب جهنم
انتقادا واستجوابات واسئله برلمانيه
النائب مضطر كذلك
لموافقه بعض الوزراء والموافقه بعض
القواعد الانتخابيه حتى يستمر كذلك يعني
تكوين ثروات الكل يعلم ان مجلس الامه كما
يقول كثير من الناس هو افضل مشروع تجاري
لاي شخص يدخل الانسان لا يملك شيء والواقع
يقول انه يخرج منه يملك ما يمكن يملكه اي
تاجر المساله مرتبطه ببعض نعم تتوقف جميع
المصالح لانه لا احد ياخذ بسده
الكل خائف من الكل للاسف نشكرك شكر جزيل
من الكويت صحفي والمحامي محمد السبتي شكرا
جزيلا